imagine comigo farinha de milho orgânica
moída e moinho de pedra daniel da monna
ganso curado e defumado da dona romilda
de prado novo queijo artesanal serrano
de bom jesus de são josé dos ausentes do
seu antônio produtos com nome sobrenome
endereço produtos com origem
deixa eu perguntar uma coisa aqui pra
vocês têm aqui você sabe o que está
comendo e que sabe de onde vêm e quem
está por trás do alimento que está no
seu prato
quando a gente sabe a origem do alimento
que a gente está comendo a gente se dá
conta que o sabor está muito ligado à
forma como esse alimento foi plantado
cuidado colhido preparado tudo fica mais
gostoso e tudo faz mais sentido que
apresenta algumas pessoas pra vocês
seu antônio santos de 58 anos e tem uma
linda que já ia de madeira que são
jardim são josé dos ausentes e produz
cinco quilos cinco quilos de queijo
artesanal serrano de leite cru
só que essa só vacas de leite da receita
e aprendeu com o pai dele há mais de 200
anos o que já é nossa e hanno é uma é um
produto de grande importância econômica
social cultural e toda a região dos
campos de cima da serra é a principal
fonte de renda de muitos produtores mas
desde 1952 1952 ele não pode ser vendido
fora do município
essa incrível senhora é a dona romilda
dona romilda tem um sítio pequeno sítio
em prado novo
onde ela queria sem ranços por ano
ela alimenta esses gansos com batata
doce que segundo ela dá uma cor linda e
um sabor inigualável carne uma vez por
ano ela bate algumas aves cura no sal
por dez dias depois de fumar em
garantirem as frutíferas por mais dez
dias
o resultado é esse peito de ganso curado
defumado essa incrível iguaria é vendida
uma feira local por um mísero valor
junto com suas cucas assados no forno à
lenha e as minhas preparados ao tacho de
cobre e se o daniel tem um pequeno sítio
oral em canela chamado monan integração
de ovelhas orgânicas galinhas caipiras
hortas e pomares
o daniel tem uma pequena plantação de
milho que o resultado das trocas
sementes nativas com os produtores da
rede
o daniel com espigas de milho de verdade
ele consegue morrer ali mesmo na cozinha
da sua casa uma incrível farinha de
milho orgânica
ele come tudo ou vêm de mercados
informais e só eu sou cozinha 20 anos
comecei a cozinhar fora do brasil e
quando voltei eu fui vender comida no
isopor na beira da praia como ambulante
um ano depois montei primeiro
restaurante em uma casinha de pescador e
anos mais tarde veio a porto alegre
montar o segundo restaurante quando eu
morava
praia a gente consumia o camarão na
frente da lagoa o peixe local e o povo
de pesca artesanal e do costão
mas o que todos nós temos em comum em
eu resolvi sair da minha cozinha em
busca do ingrediente na fonte
eu achei que não fazia muito sentido eu
ficaria esperando chegar ingredientes
que não sabia de onde vinham
quem produzia como eram feitos de
história tipo atrás deles foi inferior
comecei a pesquisar um pouco mais sobre
a cultura do nosso estado o rio grande
do sul é incrível e não é bairrismo o
rio grande do sul tem uma incrível
colonização dos alemães dos italianos da
serra dos alemães dos açorianos dos
portugueses os espanhóis na fronteira
dos índios é um gigante caldeirão de
riqueza de sabores e saberes centenas de
pequenas famílias de produtores
artesanais
a gente que faz mas essas pessoas não
sabem como vai cobrar pelo ingrediente
dela mas não sabem cobrar muitas vezes
elas têm vergonha de cobrar porque elas
não dão o devido valor a si mesmas
ela não tem idéia da preciosidade que
elas têm nas mãos
a gente entende que tem que haver uma
remuneração justa e por justa
eu entendo que a pessoa tem que viver
dignamente do que ela produza mais ainda
os filhos dessas pessoas tem que ver que
existe um futuro
mantendo a tradição da família tem que
ver que é possível viver do que elas
sabem fazer
em vez de sair da cidade vão buscar
outra atividade um quilo de queijo
serrano leva 10 litros de leite 60
para ficar pronto e é vendido a 15 reais
essa conta não fecha
o ganso curado e defumado dona romilda
leva um ano para ficar pronto e custa a
mesma coisa que um filme normal
achei que tínhamos que fazer diferente
a gente começou a criar levar seus
produtos para dentro da nossa cozinha ea
criar pratos com eles a gente acreditar
era possível agregar valor a esses
pratos com um pouco de técnica e um
pouco de criatividade e gerar uma renda
extra e gerar uma demanda adicional o
pequeno produtor
a gente sabia que podia agregar valor a
esses pratos cobrar mais por eles e
remunerar o pequeno produtor muito acima
do que o mercado local pagava a gente
criou um projeto então chamado
internacionalmente local o que
basicamente valoriza a cultura regional
e o pequeno produtor artesanal
esse projeto entre ele e mostrou a gente
fez em quando a gente entende dentro
desse projeto que a gente precisa
organizar algumas cadeias produtivas
como a natureza
o ingrediente a cozinha e o homem
a gente sabe que quando a gente
conseguir fazer isso a gente vai
conseguir oferecer um alimento bom
olimpo e justo
o alimento que é bom para quem produz
bom para quem prepara e bom pra quem o
homem nessa roda tem que girar
pensando nisso a gente criou uma linha
de produtos artesanais utilizando os
insumos dos pequenos produtores
esses produtos podem ser levados para
casa ele conta um pouco da história por
trás do ingrediente de quem produz como
é feito o que tem por trás de toda essa
cadeia alimentar diz a célebre frase de
hipócrates somos o que comemos o nosso
alimento também vejam bem o queijo
produzido em ausentes varia conforme a
qualidade do leite varia conforme a
qualidade do pasto que varia conforme a
época do ano
ausentes são josé dos ausentes num verão
pasta verde no inverno ele é adorado
pela geada e logo em seguida vêm aquelas
queimadas controladas para que renove o
passo para o ano seguinte ou seja no
verão
o queijo leite tem mais gordura e o
queijo é mais cremoso mais saboroso
no inverno o leite é mais magro e o
queijo é mais leve e mais seco
independente de nossas escolhas
se eu sou o carnívoro vegetariano
chegando eu acho importante sempre saber
de onde vem o alimento que a gente está
comendo fazer uma reflexão sobre a
origem dele como cozinheiro
eu acho saudável eu comer um churrasco
do gado de pasto de um pequeno produtor
que eu conheço todo o processo de
criação até o abate
eu não procurei procurei evitar gaga
cara de confinamento de grande indústria
mas por outro lado eu não vejo muito
sentido em ser vegetariano e comprar
alface tradicional do supermercado
quando a gente fala de intolerâncias
alimentares
a gente fala na maior parte delas de
produtos que deixaram de ser o que eles
eram muito tempo atrás
olha o trigo por exemplo o trigo foi
cortado esticado foi costurado para se
tornar em algo reconhecível
se a gente tivesse acesso ao trigo
primitivo
aquele que não continha glúten acredito
que boa parte das doenças que a gente
tem a gente não teria hoje
mas voltando o que nós todos temos em
comum e eu o daniel san antonio é dona
romilda
acho que nós temos em comum a gente
continua fazendo o que a gente sabe
fazer a gente soma a gente compartilha a
gente trabalha junto
eu acho que nós estamos aprendendo a
conhecer a dimensão do alimento e a se
preocupar em ter um alimento inteiro e
de verdade na nossa mesa
hoje em dia o seu antônio continua
produzindo seus queijos cinco quilos mas
depois de muita pressão
agora em fevereiro passado a gente
conseguiu aprovar um projeto de lei que
regulamenta a venda ea produção do
queijo serrano em todo o estado são
antônio agora vai poder vender o que
ajudaria tranquilamente a dona romilda
continua criando sem ganso dela mas
agora ela é famosa e ela aprendeu que
pode cobrar bem por isso aprendeu também
a beneficiar as penas de ganso pra
comércio e também do fígado a gente faz
patês e terrenos de ganso caipira o
sangue voltou a ser o ingrediente antigo
das tradicionais preparos como molho
pardo
eu acredito que agora ela conseguiu
realizar alguns sonhos aos 80 anos de
idade
o daniel aprender uma serraria e fazer
lindas tabelas pela gastronomia continua
cuidando das ovelhas da sua horta num
mas agora tem uma novidade nos almoços
de domingo aberta ao público
ele agora ele prepara a sua tradicional
polenta moída na hora com cordeiro
assado no fogo de chão e consul de gomes
da hora também e eu
[Música]
eu sigo tocando o projeto
internacionalmente local o seu antônio e
dona romilda com daniel e com mais 20
famílias
contínuo viajando menos que eu gostaria
mas continuam viajando conhecendo gente
conhecendo alguns produtos novos
conhecendo produtores
eu vou confessar que eu
como cozinheiro mas que nenhum deles e
traz a felicidade que eu tenho de tocar
esse projeto com essas pessoas
eu sei que a gente tem um longo caminho
ainda pela frente mas que a gente está
no caminho certo
nessa caminhada num que aprendi que a
gente precisa olhar para trás para poder
andar pra frente a gente precisa manter
os nossos hábitos e tradições
a gente precisa fazer o que a gente
sempre fez mas de um jeito um pouco
diferente
aprender na sabedoria popular dona
romilda aprender nos nossos nossos
antepassados aprendendo a nossa tradição
do nosso povo
basicamente
eu acho que é mais ou menos se alimentar
como agência me alimentava há décadas
atrás
o alimento limpo um direto de quem
produz na época dele na estação dele e
valorizando o que dita o que está por
perto
quero aqui hoje deixar uma pequena
provocação novo olhar a nossa forma de
se alimentar basicamente serviria pra
gente vai pensar que tipo de comida a
gente vai ter na nossa mesa daqui a
cinco dez anos e que nossos filhos vão
comendo
acredito que cada vez mais a gente tem a
consciência do que a gente está
escolhendo pra comer as nossas escolhas
vão determinar o quanto a gente vai
poder se alimentar de um alimento de
verdade
basicamente eu acho que saúde é a gente
saber de onde vem
conquistamos comenta obrigado
[Aplausos]